[Applause]
huh did you like meeting everybody they
just did that to me it's SoulCycle and i
was real pissed I'm not at SoulCycle to
meet people anyway I'm glad you made
some friends anyway we ready kara just
posted a photo of me on Twitter and I
think she should have called it before
healthy all right we have a lot to talk
about so I'm gonna start with this which
I have to say and then we'll move on to
a company that has been in the news of
late some things have been happening
there especially yesterday hi everybody
welcome to tonight's program with inform
at the Commonwealth Club I'm Kara
Swisher executive editor of recode and
host of the recode decode podcast and
it's my pleasure to be talking with my
friend at emotion ste he really is a
friend that's accurate a veteran
journalist currently the executive an
executive editor of fortune the
best-selling author of inside Apple here
to talk about his latest book diving
deep into the crazy world of tech and
the appalling world of tech really wild
ride
Uber's quest for world domination hello
hello Kara hello so I I text but excuse
me for interrupting we have the sale
title executive editor I didn't know
that no well that's nice
excuse me for interrupting that's an
interesting thing when we're talking
about uber so let's start with the news
of yesterday and then I want to get into
the book itself obviously it's an
interesting story but I think the news
has precluded all the history of uber
and people really do care about what
that's happening there now so let me get
your assessment yesterday was a super
busy day down to the wire
Travis finally decided to leave after a
lot of pressure he's the CEO in the
course of the day they released
recommendations that in any other
company would have gotten the CEO fired
and and then by the end of the day a
board member had to resign because he
told a joke that wasn't funny in any way
on the stage about it was it was
essentially a forum about the problems
of sexual excessive than sexual
harassment and who burned that he told
the sexist joke on
Stage two another director so it was
busy day from a news point of view it
was a woman who was a woman right
exactly so talk to me about what you
think happened yesterday because we're
just a day later essentially well you
know a couple interesting things to me
one is as you pointed out they released
Eric Holder's recommendations they did
not release his findings right the
findings would have been far more
interesting yeah I'll be releasing those
soon good I'm looking forward to that as
I'm sure everybody else is you know the
details of what he found so in other
words you have to infer everything from
from the recommendations and you can
infer a fair amount but not a lot you
don't know scale you don't know details
you don't have dirt which you know again
is is where you is where you is where
you will come in the other thing that I
think is interesting I prefer to think
of it as actually exposing ridiculous
behaviors on the part of over privileged
white denim Silicon Valley anyway but go
ahead move along
like I said okay I think if you want to
you know you made the point that any
other company would have these
recommendations would have included the
firing of the CEO I thought the precise
wording of Travis kalanick email to the
employees was interesting first of all
he's taking a leave of absence of an
undetermined length right so that could
be Monday or it could be 2019 right and
that he will continue to be involved I
believe the way put it was with the most
strategic decisions mm-hmm
I read that as him not leaving at all
right not stepping down stepping down as
CEO is sort of sort of beside the point
so I think I think or you're going with
this is it it's not over and yeah it's
clearly not over and why do you think
that tell me because it's a really
interesting situation because let me get
back to the idea that it wasn't just
that there were all these issues at the
company the report I've had parts read
it to me it's quite devastating about a
culture out of control never built run
badly breakneck speed sexual harassment
sexism all kinds of things it's like
there it was like the it was this is if
the quintessence of Silicon Valley's
problems concentrate themselves in one
come
money and and so you think that he's
still in power that he's still pulling
the pulling though I don't know how much
but I just I think even what we saw
yesterday there's there's clear evidence
that he is again I can't quantify it or
qualify it but he said I will be
involved in the most strategic decision
so who the question is why you know what
what how or how was was he able to hang
on um I think we've we've known for for
quite a while that that he has the
ability to control the board through the
form of his shares right and he had to
acquiesce and whatever they decided
right I think you would agree with me
that if he had his druthers he wouldn't
have gone at all right that's that's
certainly where he was six weeks ago or
a month ago so he was till 9:30 that
morning so things so things changed and
he he acquiesced in this but he didn't
acquiesce in leaving mm-hmm so what
explain to everyone why that is to the
board structure because he and his his
friend and close colleague Garrett camp
is the truth the truth founder of uber
right essentially control everything why
is camp sticking so closely to him you
know people have asked me as I've been
out talking about the book why wasn't
camp the CEO why did camp turn over the
reins of uber so willingly to Travis
kalanick so early and my answer has been
among the many controversial things that
have gone on at the company that wasn't
one of them nobody ever said gee Garrett
camp should have run
I've run Ober I I think and I've heard
many people say to me that Garrett camp
was grateful from the beginning that
Travis took this thing that Garrett had
created and he created you know many
little things like what this little uber
cab thing was in 2009 and made it into
Ober so I think Garrett camp was very
comfortable with that he's been grateful
um he was the really the first person to
take serious money out of the company
and one of the very few people to take
serious money out of the company he was
grateful to Travis for that mm-hmm
so I just I don't think it's any more
complicated than so he doesn't want more
serious money because at this point m'm
ajan this company go public with that
with that CEO because public going
public is the goal presumably of the
company can you know I don't even before
this week even before last month I
didn't think they were gonna go public
anytime soon so I don't know what can
change mm-hmm let's say it's 2019 that's
a long time from now
I understand log years yeah I understand
that but it's not dog ears in well in
terms of being a financial leader in a
public company correct yeah I understand
and what you know we can discuss the
morality of it but we know that Silicon
Valley at Silicon Valley venture
capitalists will tolerate almost
anything if they can make if they can
make their almighty buck right and I I
think there's ample evidence that the
same exam is true for public
shareholders there's almost no evidence
well I shouldn't say there's certainly
been instances of CEOs being drummed out
for one transgression or another I'm not
saying people don't care and I'm not
saying that you know it's a slam dunk
thick Olynyk will be the CEO when this
company goes public but it doesn't it
wouldn't shock me right more insight
because I don't think there are morals I
agree with you I think the there's a lot
of issues around the way MOU lawsuit yep
criminal indictments around several
different things I expect if Anthony
Levin dowse key who were ultimately
fires faces any kind of criminal
investment any kind of criminal problems
he I don't imagine he would not roll
over and point upward presumably that's
how it seems to work those are the kind
of things I'm more interested in yeah so
huge I mean existential threats so you
know forgive me for mentioning the book
but it's it's germane to your to your
question which is you know it might the
final chapter includes this anecdote
where Travis Kelly and I take this long
walk through San Francisco we walk four
hours from headquarters down to the
Ferry Building to almost to the Golden
Gate Bridge and I said that's such a
thing with internet executives taking a
long walk
I think I think Steve Jobs was like a
walker and a talker to never walk with
them believe me I would rather I would
rather have been sitting at a table
taking notes yeah yeah my reporter
sitting right here on your lawn said I'm
walking down the street holding my
record right my hand okay yeah right I'm
getting it yeah so I did so you're on
the romantic walk up yeah we're on it
we're gonna grab romantic walk me and my
buddy mm-hmm
and I do remember where I was going with
this okay he told me he told me at some
point during during that conversation
you know there's there's one other
person I take this walk with frequently
but I can't tell you who it is yet Oh
God it was Anthony Levin down ski and
this was before the auto purchase which
was why he couldn't why he couldn't tell
me about it so you know I published that
other people have published that that
they walked together the the the the
judge has specifically said that he's
allowing way mo to interview anybody who
has had any interaction with Levin Dow
ski on the subject of this acquisition
which means that this which means that
the the content the content and the
context of their conversations while
they were having this romantic walk and
he's going to be germane right so anyway
it's you know it's quite serious right
because you know way Moe's alleging
theft of training the way master waitwe
Moe is this I don't I think it's a
terrible name would agree yeah so way
Moe is the renamed Google self-driving
car unit it's actually not part of
Google now it's part of alphabets
because it's an other bet or something
like that but but way Moe has sued uber
because it says that Anthony Levin dau
ski who worked as an engineer for the
Google self-driving unit when that's
what it was called left started a new
company called auto sold it for eight
hundred or six hundred forty million
dollars very quickly to uber and they
are they allege that this was a burrs
way of stealing their technology and
embedded in this is that and that this
hasn't happened yet but if the the next
step would be that that's fraudulent
behavior yeah not not merely
stealing of trade secrets no and they
also didn't sue Anthony they sued uber
uber which presumably has more assets
then I don't think that's why anything
to be and to knock them out of the box
yeah well and because maybe they did
something wrong I know crazy to imagine
all sorts of ways somebody could do
something wrong
right there's also and there's and it so
uber has tried vociferous ly to settle
to go to mediation the judge disallowed
that uber obviously would would rather
write a check and and my only point is
that Google alphabet doesn't seem to be
too interested in receiving a check also
Google doesn't really need money just
that's my point
yeah they're kind of rich we just
recently had Ruth Parade on stage on our
KOAT conference and talked about that
and I said Google never in fact Google
usually pays people they don't like even
to leave you know and I mean even if
they like and I said well you don't
usually sue people and she says we don't
usually sue people and I said but you're
suing uber and she goes oh yes we're
suing oberon and I said so that's
different she goes oh yeah that's
different and I think they're very
intent on taking this down to the wire
that's that's a big issue let's talk a
little bit about the book and getting to
accept but because all this does matter
in terms of what's gonna happen in this
company I think they're in much more
serious trouble than most people do but
let's talk about the genesis book when
you started the book it was like look at
this you know bare-knuckled
start-up that's changing the world and
this pugnacious in your face CEO who's
just you know it's such a character kind
of thing tell me that's sort of what you
were thinking about when you wanted to
church when I started which was when I
sort of started thinking about it was
2014 or so and what what I was
witnessing was this company that being
at that point barely four years old had
already expanded around the world very
quickly of course they'd done it in
their second year of operation right and
that fascinated me in particular because
I had just I was only you know at that
point eighteen months out of publishing
a book about Apple mmm-hmm and uber
wouldn't have been able to go around the
world without the iPhone without the App
Store the app stores everywhere the
iPhones everywhere so uber could be
everywhere very quickly in a way that
startups couldn't have done in another
era that other era being five or ten you
earlier and they had raised already
billions of dollars they already had a
multi billion dollar valuation they had
had this profound impact on taxi systems
in many places so I thought and think
that it was and is an important story
and that it was if you believe that this
that this app revolution was was serious
I was far more and am far more
interested in what the app enabled then
then phrases like the gig economy or the
sharing economy and I believe that it
was the it was the best example of what
this this thing could power well they
also talked about the uber of do that
anymore but what you know well if it
helps them raise money they will but
yeah I don't think it's a good but you
so the idea was that this was a
different how was it different cuz it is
one of the few several Airbnb I guess
and some others that have come out of
this next year of Silicon Valley well
what I think was compelling about it was
that it was both an internet digital
software company and a hard assets
people company that involved messy
things like regulators and and drivers
and cars and transportation networks in
a way that Facebook and Google and Yahoo
weren't not purely digital and in the
way that Apple which was you know this
amazing hardware company with software
wasn't really an internet wasn't an
Internet company and you and that that
that it represented what from your
perspective the the next you know the
next stage of these these kinds of
companies that we that we cover it was
it was if you will if you put them in uh
if you put them in buckets or or phases
of evolution from the you know the
companies that existed around Microsoft
and Intel to the companies that existed
around Google or Yahoo and google and
then the companies that existed around
Facebook and Twitter and whatnot this
was the next thing and I thought that
was interesting and what do you think
made them stand out from from what
they're doing I did a profile Travis a
couple years ago for Vanity Fair and a
lot of it had to do with his early years
most of which
were not great he presided over two
relatively failed startups one
completely failed very difficult
relationships with almost every investor
he had and everything ended in tears for
this guy a lot oh yeah yeah and he he
just created a lot of trouble where ever
you know it just seemed like he was at
the Nexus of trouble and then was like I
can't believe this trouble and so a lot
of the stuff was to me to be motivated
by rage about that he you know he had
sort of a rage at its heart that is very
different than other contra printers and
older and also older yeah so I I'm not
I'm not I don't think necessarily that I
wanna know what you think motivated him
yeah well I don't think that the well I
don't know if the if the rage accounted
for a success certainly for his ultimate
success with uber if we call it that I
think there was a period of time when
that would have been a less
controversial statement it's a more
controversial statement you know he's
clearly and I talked about in the book
he said he's a stubborn and persistent
relentless ruthless person and so those
things became important in uber but the
part of the story that I think is really
interesting you know he was part of this
company he was part of the founding team
of this company called Scour which is
you say went completely belly-up and
then he did something that was
essentially not Napster APRI Napster but
less successful and less meteoric so it
started and failed more quickly than the
Napster did and read swoosh the next
company was an iteration of that
technology intended to be legitimate it
was legitimate they sold the
corporation's instead but it took
forever to get going and then it was
down to one person him at one point
ultimately he sold it for what nobody in
the valley would would consider you know
a lot of money and he had a lot of
successful friends around him yeah and
and and the the the point I was driving
to is that that that happened in off the
time I had 2008 I think um you know I've
been here since 1997 I tend to know the
people who are you know who are modestly
successful I never knew the guy I met
him in 2010 after uber was starting to
go up now I only point that out to say
that he wasn't one of these eight plus
players but by the time by the time uber
came around he was a player in that
world but we could quickly name 20
people who were more important so
there's a lot of there's a lot of luck
involved this was the this was like the
right thing and by the way you know
right when he decided that he was going
to go to her and I loved it like I love
all these references to him having
founded uber which simply simply isn't
the case although you know you could
argue I did a book on AOL Steve Case
didn't found AOL but he kind of found it
and he made it in Howard Schultz didn't
found Starbucks but he made it right not
not that not to take away from him but
Garrett camps idea was an important one
he Travis kalanick was around when they
started operations so so so so he was
the founder in that regard but what do
you think Moe today I want to get to
what Morrison guys spent time with his
parents including his mom who just died
tremendously lovely woman his father was
a civil engineer I think his mother sold
newspaper ads they lived went to their
house it was a very modest house above
Los Angeles in Northridge brother is a
firefighter or I think sister's nurse I
think something like that somebody works
at Kinkos yeah yeah just real modest but
lovely people and very funny and I
couldn't believe these were I thought he
hired these people like where's the mean
mom and the abusive father and it really
interesting because you know it was sort
of an unusual place from to come so I'd
love to know what you think how that
happened so I would love to tell you
that I found that I found Travis's
rosebud and I absolutely set out to find
it I asked people who knew him back then
you know what do you think his rosebud
was what was what was motivating him he
tells me this story in the book about
when he was an Indian guy do you know
what Indian guides were they're no
longer called Indian guides but um it
was a program run by the YMCA virtue for
boys to spend more time with their dads
hi also Indian guy was an Indy it was an
Indian guide about 10 years before
before Travis was and he tells me this
story about a fundraising drive for a
camping trip or something for the Indian
guides where they sold pancakes in front
of the supermarket or tickets to the
pancake you know event in front of the
supermarket and he was bound and
determined at age 10 or whatever to sell
the most
freaking pancake said repeatedly than
any other Indian guidance so he'd stay
there until you know the wee hours of
the night in order to do that but the
point was that he was motivated like
that at a very young age he was driven
but you know if he was being beaten in
the in the basement by his lovely mother
or his or his hard-working father I
don't know about right okay but that
either no I mean as far as a hunter and
had waffles of dead animal heads which
was disturbing but but he exactly not
not many in the internet space but yeah
that's true so but it was interesting
because he talked about bullying that's
why you know a lot about being bullied
yeah he was teased you know he was a he
was a mathlete of sorts but but he was
also an athlete he was a good runner
good baseball player so you know he sort
of played both those positions and he
you know yeah he he he tells stories
about having been bullied for being a
nerd mm-hmm
that was a bad word probably growing up
in Northridge it's a badge of honor in
Silicon Valley but but I never got I
didn't get the sense from him telling
those stories that there were deep
emotional scars yeah got made fun of he
got teased yeah a lot of kids get to you
yeah I always thought he made it up but
anyway well I'm just giving you I'm not
saying that but I'm my impression is is
that it wasn't so funny why the reason
I'm talking about his personality cuz
you know maybe he's just an [ __ ] that
could be just you know I mean that
really is often the biggest donation for
a lot of people in Silicon Valley but
what do you think got them different
like what did you come to the conclusion
but what was it the city was that the
app was that though what was it you know
yeah the Kulish the cliche these people
love to talk about his product market
fit and they had it they you know the
they had it in the sense that anyone who
wrote a taxi in San Francisco before
uber came along knew that the experience
sucked you might get picked up you might
not if you called for one it might come
it might not you might make it to the
airport ah yeah I mean they figured out
a an abundantly
better way of doing that and it was it
you know again cliche but I felt it I
remember feeling it it was magical wow
this just works mm-hmm so there was a
great market it was a it's a it's a big
market and they and they hit it hard
it's interesting to remember that they
they built it up by doing a limousine
product yes it was a fancy wanted to
ride around and that was what they
wanted right they wanted to be ballers
and to ride a ride around town and I
know it's not I just recalled I'm saying
it to me when I was like you remember
him saying you say all of them well and
and and this in the story that I love to
tell is that the first time I met him I
hadn't I don't know if I had ridden uber
or not but I had used it to send our
babysitter home because I thought it was
a great I could I didn't have to take
home and I could watch her progress and
made sure make sure that she got home
and I could pay for it I thought that
was great and I told him this I said you
know I got a great idea for you you need
to market this as a great thing he's
like could could not have been less
interested in the babysitter right now
but well but they I'm not know your
business not mine but about that
question but they built it out they
built out this you know this this
product that worked well by having this
limousine why was it better than a lyft
or whatever that's my swim
that's when well it was better lyft
wasn't doing it wasn't doing that at the
time lyft what we now know is lyft had a
business called Zimride which was
organizing right for corporate campuses
at night and in university campuses you
lift then had the idea let's pivot take
this idea make it into a way that we can
power ordinary people with their cars
and by the way we'll make it we can make
the calling part look a lot like what
Ober is when it took uber some time to
realize that they had been they'd been
beaten right once they realized they'd
been beaten they were able to move
really quickly into lifts yep brought up
because they had because the app worked
right they were already established all
around the country and in other parts of
the world which lift wasn't and they had
a lot of money so barrettes
creating barracks right exactly so have
you strike the differences between those
two companies I couldn't be more
different in terms of the CEOs for
example I mean Zimmer is really I don't
know how to even describe I mean he's
just really he came over one time to I
was seeing Dick Costolo and someone else
do who used to be the CEO of Twitter and
he said he came where he goes you know
Kara the reason reason I'm doing this is
because eighty percent of the car is not
in use and that's wrong for our planet
like he's right there's one person
sitting in the car there's five I got it
like it was eighty percent it's just
think about that and I was wrong and I
feel like I can save the world that way
and he really meant it it wasn't like
some [ __ ] you know what I mean like
he really meant it and he walked away
and DeCosta turned to me and said Travis
don't kill him
[Laughter]
uber talks about the same exact
statistic but they talk about it in
terms of unused inventory yet right and
then and and there are even their
offices like this you go in and you get
a foot massage it lifts and then they
give you fresh kombucha and then there's
pink everywhere it's lovely and then you
go to Ober and it looks like a Bond
movie and you think we better the Death
Star the Death Star and you think I
better not stand on these stairs because
it's gonna open up in the shark like I
think about that all the time and then
their room which Arianna just redubbed
the peace room was called the war room
yeah when you get off the elevator at
uber it's store like those cells in Soho
were you a little scared because you're
not sure yeah it's way to turn or a the
floor wall yeah yeah yeah it's true what
is the difference between them cuz like
the war room is a perfect example when I
was let in there for the first time I
was like you've got to be kidding they
let you in there yeah but I was like
you're kidding and they're like Witek
it's great I think I said I think you're
twelve-year-old boys but okay but that
was different so what was the mentality
what was the difference between those
two well the funny thing about the way
you introduced that is it Zimmer isn't
even the CEO you know the slogan green
nobody knows the CEO also real nice very
nice and there so but you know look we
we all go with what we've got right and
I I think I think lyft is gone that's
who they are right and
is who they are is that the difference
or the over the the obnoxiousness the
pushing around of regulators the sort of
ugly statements that he would make that
he would you talked about on the book
quite a bit that he'd just pop off with
a statement that was usually somewhere
between appalling and disgusting itself
at any one point I think if yes I think
that this is this is who Travis is it's
not it's not a corporate strategy but it
has it been I'm just curious if you
think it has it been as it made them
successful has it been the reason
they've been able to bear all their way
through city after city there's no
question in my mind although it's it's
it's hard to it's hard to separate the
the bravado or they are the attitude
from the actions because it's again it's
at a it's worth pointing out that that
lift was the first to do a dam the
regulator strategy yeah say we don't
think these taxi rules apply to us so
we're gonna do it anyway and ubers ubers
respond over did a white paper I think
Travis wrote a white paper said we think
this is illegal and we're concerned
about that and they had conversations
about it then they said oh well okay it
may be illegal but we better do it
quickly or we're gonna get beaten by
these guys but so but what you're
talking about is yes they they sort of
you know led with their chin they said
we're not gonna be like a little sneaky
about the regulatory issue we're gonna
be completely transparent that we don't
you know we don't care right and we're
gonna go in and we're gonna start
operating and when they come to us to
say we think you're illegal we're gonna
fight with them and we're gonna get
people to we're gonna get drivers and
riders to be on our side and we forget
in 2017 that there was this moment when
uber was beloved you know headlines
saying what a great thing this is people
saying how much they love their uber
rides and so early on they did that but
let's get to sneaky because sneaky was
seems to be their like favorite move on
lots of things not just great balling
but there's it goes back in history yeah
like one sneaky move what's the word
that they used to call if drivers I'm
blanking on its its but anyway they do
all kinds of sneaky it was it was
Operation slog where that bogging where
they gave people burner phones which you
know the I only knew the expression
burner from the wires with drug dealers
burners anonymous phones to call for
rides
then cancel them or take the ride and
say you know you really ought to be
driving for uber uber you know I
interviewed this guy who worked at at
red swoosh who told me that that Travis
so this is 20 years ago would there be
they'd have a whiteboard or whatever the
version of a whiteboard was then and he
would write like a dollar sign with big
numbers on the whiteboard and this guy
said to me you know I'd go by there and
the number that they would JIT was he
just wrote a large number for people who
would be walking by to see the large
number all right it was shifty yes
shifty so what is that at the heart of
the company the shiftiness because every
to we you know every two weeks you think
it's sort of one thing after the next I
mean you know the one person's shifty is
another person's pushing the envelope I
think great bowling is being criminally
investigated so that's not shifty that's
criminal so we what do you think that
does is that is that it is that
something that you can get you
successful to a certain point but not
fully correct well if by not fully you
mean not profitable yes and if by not
fully you mean you know brings uh bring
brings a storm down on you that ends up
having real ramifications on the company
then yeah right so I want to get to when
you were doing the research look why do
it why continue because it doesn't
really work it's not it doesn't
ultimately work you get found out and
now you know you sort of you sort of
have a target on your back
almost cuz people just assume that
you're gonna live them assume you're
going to be aggressive assume do you
think it's it's a good strategy and then
we'll get it to where they're going next
but when you were doing the research for
this book it seems like it's a
never-ending theme of that company
correct
it's not the it's number one it's not
the only theme it's not like it's I
don't I certainly don't
they didn't project to me or I didn't I
didn't have the daily feeling like this
is a criminal enterprise I have had
people say to me well don't you think I
like a mafia organization and I didn't I
I didn't have that feeling I mean yeah
there's like and some of the things and
I know we're gonna get to this some of
the things I simply didn't know about I
didn't I didn't uncover but I you know
along the way I saw plenty of good and I
mean look if it were a if I did think it
were a criminal enterprise I don't get
to go as far as criminal enterprise it's
not like it's the Gotti family here but
you know what I mean like there's a lot
of when they have a choice to do
something a little sneaky possibly
criminal or the right way it seems this
is the shift that they get all I'm
saying is that there's probably a good
book in the Gotti family I'm sure there
have been mother Sopranos but go ahead
yeah well right and and and others right
and and so I see my role as a journalist
to to write about the Gotti family right
and so well and to tell the story and
you know maybe we could have a we could
have a conversation about the the notion
of passing judgment I think my style is
to is to present it analyze it and tell
it in a in an entertaining way okay and
you get to judge yeah so you see when
you did though you still can come to
conclusions correct I don't disagree
with that yeah so what conclusion did
you come is this a sustainable is this
is what made it no way it is because
it's not like any company we've covered
I think you and I can both agree I mean
you don't you would never think Facebook
behaves like this although they've done
plenty of sneaky things but it's not the
same you know I'm thinking of all the
companies we covered is there a closed
the only closed company I can think of
is Microsoft and even even he looks like
a like a little kitten comparatively but
he's not promise you I'll answer you I I
I once had this conversation with uh
with Mark Zuckerberg like I saw like the
lightning quick win win and intelligence
when I someone else at fortune was
working about to start a feature story
and I said you know we're just starting
this feature story and I you know I
think we're really concerned about some
of these Russian billionaires who are
oligarchs who are involved in you know
in killing people being investors in
Facebook and without batting an eye he
said to me I'm glad you're not working
you're not writing the story and so I
don't think let me let me rephrase that
I think there's good people doing good
work and doing you know good corporate
work made over okay and I don't think
that takes a
from I don't think that takes away from
your question and the things that you're
talking about I think it's possible to
do what they're doing without being
shifty and the example would be that
lyft is doing it right you have a
separate conversation about is this a
real business can it ever be a business
I also think the answer is yes okay I
can't prove it right no one else can
either so wait there's good people it's
still this week it's shown it's just
rained down on those good people they're
sucked into a middle of incredible
misbehavior and yeah I want to get to
the financial parts of it too you know
how you think about the business going
forward and all these businesses but but
talk a little bit about I told you I was
gonna ask this question but in this book
nowhere do we have any really small
amounts of oh they're such bros and
they're so tough and this and that know
where any of the stuff that Susan
Farrell allege same thing in the Brad
stone book there it's as if it didn't
exist now that's all that's not all that
matters but it's what's causing all the
problems is this explosive blog post by
a very brave woman named Susan Fowler
who worked there who was alleging sexism
sexual harassment and essentially just
corporate malfeasance I think that's
really it's more so than anything else
it's how they run a company like it was
a an episode of Game of Thrones
essentially that it was a constant the
managers were untrained there was no
eight report things there were no HR
systems in place and I think goobers
excuses the whole time to me and others
has been well we've been so fast
building it we had no ability to change
to do this which to me is sort of I
didn't clean my bedroom excuse like it
you don't I mean are you kidding me like
you can't put in normal assistants so
why did I'm gonna say why'd you miss
this because there there was a little
sexual harassment problem going on there
was a sexism problem there was a party
problem there was a you know a sort of
careless behavior towards employees and
drivers and literally it's pervasive
through this company it's hard to miss
so for okay so first of all first of all
not know where I I have a whole section
yeah it was that was you know
strengthened after the after the initial
manuscript and I'm very well it was it
was it was strengthened by by my two
editors who are women mm-hmm and
where I discuss the Alex's and Fowler's
allegation right which happened after I
which came out after I turned in my
manuscript and the subject of women in
uber more generally right that's number
one had been raised for years the safety
of women passengers and I yeah and I and
I and I and I addressed it in a you know
we you can you can judge me on how if I
addressed it in not forcefully I don't
mind it yeah I understand that and you
know and secondly so to the extent that
because this is an important element of
the story shame on me shame on me that I
didn't that I didn't get it adequately
you know you also mentioned Gabe
Sherman's book compared to that Roger
Ailes where he wrote this you know this
scathing expose of Roger Ailes and no
were in there did he mention this the
rampant allegations of sexual harassment
well it wasn't rampant allegations of
sexual harassment at News Corp or at F
Fox News it was we later learned
multiple settlements of sexual
harassment site which had been and the
terms of which had been that those
people didn't talk about it right so
this is Gabe Sherman's were this is Gabe
Sherman's reporting right and I my issue
is that you couldn't like you couldn't
cover Fox News without knowing his
reputation did you did you know about
this stuff and not write about or did
you just feel it was like nothing or is
it an issue of covering Silicon Valley
that people turn a blind eye to some
really serious things which you to
reference with you know Silicon Valley
venture capitalists don't care anything
about except about the getting of the
pay off essentially you know I
interviewed women on the record his book
I interviewed women off the record for
this book and this subject didn't come
up so if you're asking me did I not know
I didn't know right and I and if you
know and so if you want to say well why
didn't you why were you looking harder
for it why didn't I push harder on it
fine you know I spoke I spoke to women
who complained to me about how they were
treated by their managers right because
they were jerks essentially or whatever
or whatever word Arianna I think I
talked to women who described the you
know the the
the work occasions you know work ation
you know they would send teams to places
to launch a city and they would all go
out partying at night who told me about
it you know as being one of the things
they love the most a tuber so all I all
I can do is tell you what what my report
they told you so and I canned and and I
could have done more and I could have
done better
were you aware of the memo we published
last week from Travis the party memo no
I I had in in the back of my brain I
remember that I had before I ever
started we explain what the PA you
published a memo that Travis wrote this
he felt compelled for some reason to
write a memo to his employees before an
off-site in Miami saying giving them a
ground rules on how they should behave
at the meeting I think it includes
something like don't have sex with
someone who's your subordinates what at
what else well don't throw it don't
vomit because it costs $200.00 don't
throw kegs off of roofs off of Rosia
which is like what like you shouldn't be
like okay and then don't have sex with
someone in your direct report but if you
decide to have sex or three of you do
don't make sure everybody's consensual
which ever ok good advice
but from a frat guy not at CEO of a
company and then at the last part which
I thought was to me the crowning glory
of this particular appalling memo was I
can't have sex with anyone cuz I'm the
CEO and then hashtag F FML which is
[ __ ] my life meaning he's lamenting
not being able to have sex with his
employees which i think is not
appropriate for a CEO II just my I know
I'm strict about these things but though
as I I'm saying that memo was famous
within Ober like that whoo we're such
ballers so to say that we tell me if I
have my factory you're going to hear a
piece with 2014 yes I didn't not yes no
no earlier earlier than that but it was
after the Miami thing I don't know I
don't remember yeah but I so you know
I'm saying what happens that this gets
overlooked I'm not saying I'm not gonna
give you the blend necessarily but it
does get overlooked in Brad's book it's
not there and Gabe's book it's not there
what I want you to talk about a bigger
issue around Silicon Valley that even
the women you interviewed didn't or
like I don't say just women its men no
but if anyone's gonna bring it up at
unsolicited when I say tell me what I
need to know right you would think it
would be women right and I think so you
know I can't do any better than it then
answer your questions as directly as I
can I think that when you read when you
read my book you will get a sense of an
immature grown-up running an immature
company right and and so so I don't I
think I I think I got that and after the
you know after the again after I turned
in the manuscript and that video of him
narrating the driver came out that
became a viral sensation and he said
that he needed to he needed to grow up
right point out toward the end of the
book this was a man who had recently
entered his fifth decades yeah he's
saying them yeah so you know by the way
I also wrote an uber with him and the
the driver recognized that he had the
CEO of uber in the back seat and started
to really give him the business like you
don't understand this isn't working
right I can't get my emails answered on
that and they did an email he said I'm
gonna follow up with you and then of
course you very quickly late late at
night he he copied me on the email I
letter said you know did you do that
because I was in the back yes no of
course not I do I do that all right but
I'm saying what do you think gets the
culture of it that this was very
different there's sexual sexism and
sexual last minute every company we
cover but nothing of this thing and then
also will it change at uber because
again just last week we wrote about this
India thing which was I think what
pushed it over the edge was that that he
for those who don't know he he they got
the medical records of a rape victim
nuber customer and we're essentially
questioning her story blaming it on ola
this is the CEO Oh looking their
competitor in Indiana and then carrying
them around for a year of medical
records of a rape in a criminal case and
I'm just I'm saying does it change
because that was literally last week
kind of thing that we're doing that and
then they lied to the New York Times
about it when they asked about it and
they never New York Times didn't write
about it so burr is a this is a
situation where on an almost daily basis
recently things happen
that you couldn't make up if you try can
you imagine
empty a meeting with the employees for
the board members to explain to them
what they're gonna do next and this you
know this revered financier David
Bannerman making a sexist comment at at
Arianna Huffington's approach at that
expense at that meeting right so I'm
wondering do you think spending all this
time with this company and saying there
are good people there do you imagine
these recommendations are gonna be taken
seriously and that they will change you
just made a face like because I given
the scrutiny that they're under that
it's going to be hard for them not to
not to take them seriously and so they
will Institute you know when you read
through the holder recommendation there
there's sort of like they're like
operating manuals for how you're
supposed to do human resource yeah Dell
Institute they'll institute those
changes and if and I don't know if it
will swell you so much inside this
company I think I think they have a shot
at making those things stick because
because I don't believe that every
person is rotten and I'm not making no I
get that that's what I mean I'm not
making any excuses for the people who
are right but do you believe that this
culture can because sometimes you as you
know a lot of cultures are the DNA of
their founders or their immediate
creators and they don't change and I'll
just you know I'll make an observation
when I when I spent I think Apple was
thirty or thirty five years old when I
when I did my book on them and it was a
huge education for me because I had
always discounted the the notion of
corporate culture I thought was one of
those soft topics that people don't you
know have anything real to talk about
talk about and I decided I was
completely wrong at Apple the culture
was everything absolutely and it was a
three decade plus old company
Hoover's hope has to be that a six or
seven ish year old company that the
culture isn't as ingrained mm-hmm I
don't think I mean I'd like to be
optimistic for them right right you
think no chance I think you know I think
chance I I think I'm a maya angelou fan
and her quote is when someone shows you
their face for the first time believe
them you know what I mean I just do I
think they I think companies are what
they're born like and they have every
single company we know as an element of
that let's get to their finances we just
have a few minutes questions really soon
from
I'm sure you have lots of them for Adam
the financials losing a ton of money
billions and billions a lot of people
they like to try to compare themselves
at uber to Amazon why Amazon lost a lot
of money and then they became what they
are today
Amazon built a lot of moats they built
warehouses they built its various
different systems Amazon didn't have any
real rivals they really didn't if you
really think about they had small rivals
but nothing real the big retailers never
got in the game that was never a head in
there was never a lift version of an
Amazon competitor and in or an Ola or a
DD ever they were quite a few and they
were bad yeah that's yeah but they
didn't they never had a real Li Cyrano
better but they built moats everywhere
they went they built notice and now they
were benefiting from those modes they
get it yeah
does uber went losing this much money
you said I think there's a business
there can you explain how that cuz I'm
that's something that I feel is not the
case yeah even with what they release we
don't have a super clear view about the
finances are they're fairly opaque so
what we know is that they that for a
while they were losing a ton of money in
China they stopped that they're losing a
ton of money by trying to build a India
and India business yeah they're losing a
ton of money by investing heavily in
their very own version of autonomous
vehicles which we talked earlier could
could end up ending in tears for them
but that's expensive right there that's
bringing in zero revenue so the question
is does the business itself have a shot
at bringing in money there you know
there was evident there's been evidence
at various stages of their development
that it had the that it had the
possibility to bring in a lot of money
and you know let's take just take the
United States
uber and lyft are in this are in this
arms race
you could also envision a scenario where
you know not by collusion but because
they you know we've either spent
themselves into exhaustion right that
they both pull off these subsidies and
they make money right but - but the
flipside of that is already we go around
town and we see drivers who have the
lift now and the uber right you kill on
the same window because it's
interchangeable to them I guess I'm
asking is there a moat for them given
all this because to me their biggest
thing was their brand and that's not
that's right the best moat was that
they'd become a verb
uber there yeah and it was it was easy
to explain and people around the country
and around the world knew it mm-hmm and
that you know they've been they've been
severely tarnished yeah but you know I
don't have the day of the data at their
fingertips I thought everything's fine
what's that they have been saying well
I'm not saying that they had said that
the data that would be interesting to
know is what what consumer behavior is
like there's you know anecdotally
there's places where people just take
uber right and it's for anecdotally I'm
not gonna take it anymore well I was
gonna say no but that's the more like in
our circles that's the more prevailing
thing I won't do that but there's people
out there who do my mom does want to
take it over and I understand its
interest your mom no she's not very
technical she's just like you but she's
aware of way yeah I think it's
interesting
we'll see if what also a woman's like
Travis no so so but but in any case this
is a last question and we'll get the QA
when you have that idea of like this
brand is the most important thing and
it's not just this sexualized nothing
it's not just way mo it's not just great
balling before that was delete uber were
they trying to screw people are going to
the protests it's like every single day
it feels very trumpian like what oh I
forgot he insulted someone who is
disabled that was months ago
you know I mean there seems like can
connect brand sustain this much because
you cover brands for years Internet
brands brands can rejuvenate if they do
if they do things right you know you
need the right people on the right money
on the right strategy I'm not telling
but I'm not telling you anything you
don't know it's yeah
so who's the CEO Oh gonna be who does it
have to be well if they're looking for a
CEO doing for a CMO and see if I was
there looking at if there's engineering
only because we've gotten some of these
people fired so I'm no the head of no
product had a business yeah that guy
he's gone if they if there's ever a
conversation I'd like to be a fly on the
law and it's this guy you know the
conversation with the top prospect he
says well okay explain one thing to me
who do I report to we had to report to
Travis kalanick but he's not there right
now right right when's he coming back
hey I don't know yeah you know what are
my specific responsibilities they're
gonna be well they're gonna be these but
and how do I know that's not going to
change when Travis comes back
because we say so right and we're a very
weak board and have never stopped him
before and we're complicit in all this
activity but at least come yeah it's a
toughy so you know they're the person
they want who would you think wants to
be CEO
not-not-not see oh oh right who would
you pick pick two names I mean the the
what's that Jared Chris he we've just
added that to his portfolio yeah you got
one you just wait
we just added it to his portfolio but go
ahead he's solving Middle East peace
they could do it on this Oh added whose
portfolio running over right now that's
oh that's that's a great idea I mean two
people who one has been one the names
been floated as the former the former
heir apparent at Disney I can't run
stacks Staggs right TST tags you know
he's a guy who's a business guy who's
running a complicated operation and done
it very diplomatic guy you had him on
stage thank you no I'm well he's the
kind of person yeah who would who would
do it and who would work as close to Tom
Staggs go uh okay well I and what sense
no no he doesn't want her no good no
thank you
maybe there's enough money in the world
I don't know that was a bit but you know
you know again I'm talking about types
of people the type of person who'd be
perfect in this situation if he wanted
to do it would be Alan Mulally the
former school board who had who had been
the CEO since ocular well he gets
complex organizations he knows how to
knows how to like wrap things up in a
bow and and he I don't know how old he
is but he doesn't need know either the
recognition he really can rock a sweater
vest which is a great sweat question the
audience come on up where the question
we have it right here okay go for it son
so Kara thanks for your time Adam as
well and for bringing Ruth always an
added plus Kimberly's referring to my
wife sitting in the front right here
it's better happen I really mean it that
way question my question is Adam you've
had this amazing opportunity to write
about inside Apple and now in kind of
inside uber water was
one similarity or one difference of
these two companies with pretty unique
CEOs well superficially there's a lot of
similars a lot of similarities you know
jobs was jobs prided himself and
breaking the rules yeah large and small
not so large as uber has but that was
part of that was part of his persona and
you know I wrote I wrote a thing this
morning that you know Travis told me
once I said how do you like running a
big company and I think it was a very
telling response he said I like to think
of it in small pieces and when I and I
and I you know I reflected in the book
and and again that I don't think he had
grasped that that wasn't acceptable you
know he's running a big company right
but - but but in fairness so you know
from a storytelling perspective that was
one of jobs as lines he said I like to
think that apples the largest startup in
the world he made it work he was he was
Steve Jobs it was not a small company it
had who had a ton of professional
processes and you know you would hear
these stories about people screw you
know being screamed at by Steve Jobs and
others being treated horribly but
there's no you know that that's not
that's not against the rules
that's not against the law no screaming
it screaming at people because you think
they suck yeah I know that's where the
comparisons end I would not compare them
in any way well I'm talking about in in
let's say an aspirational tone in in
ubers aspiration that I don't that's
fine sorry
no jobs was very great CEO sorry hi
there
so I should probably preface this by
saying that I haven't read take a wild
override but I'd love to know from the
both of you what you think is the sort
of realistic and practical future of
uber given a lot of the shortcomings
that we've talked about tonight
amongst leadership management and
culture
well I've I think I've I think I've
ticked it that you've got a company with
a I'm gonna give you the cup half full
because Cara's gonna give you the cup
half empty which which I'm fine with I
could give you that too but it's a
there's a company with with global
operations and sort of I'm reaching for
a business cliche which is mine share in
the
with with consumers with riders and so
you know huge problems including these
legal problems which are way worse maybe
then the public perception problems or
the reputation being tarnished but if
you could get past that if they can't if
they can get past that and and you and
you you bring in the right leadership to
run that global operation that would be
the cup half full yeah future I would
say the sexual harassment sexism suffers
stepdad Lee I will say they will
probably get over that if they do the
right things they shouldn't they should
not but I think the lawsuits are really
problematic
I think the criminal investigations are
problematic I think the fact that they
have a very thin management staff and
how do you attract really good people
there you're not going to get a Sheryl
Sandberg to show up there she's just
never good someone like that it's never
gonna do that so you have all these
problems of attrition
keeping staff keeping drivers happy
there's so many this is such a
logistically complex company to have the
the mind share of really hard and then I
think that they I think they're gonna
get sold that's what I would say who go
to Google yeah they can't compete in the
self-driving area that you can't do it
they just can't they're not the most
brilliant okay there's a players and B
players and now they don't have the a
players anymore you know and they've
managed to create one of the most toxic
cultures I've ever seen
in tech and so I think they it's just
like I don't know who could go in and of
course and then you have the CEO
floating around saying I really need to
get to this drives me nuts
you know uber needs to get to over 2.0
and Travis needs to get to Travis 2.0
it's like it's all going to rest on his
Jesus like shoulders and that
mentalities you know is so Silicon
Valley and I think here's someone who
created most of the damage not taking
responsibility for it not having any
kind of sorry there's not a real sorry
here and I don't want like I don't you
don't need to prostrate yourself but
David Bonderman whatever you think of
that joke and I think he meant something
slightly different when he said I think
he was talking about having discussions
with women went there's more discussion
with more women around the table it was
a bad stupid joke at the exactly wrong
time but he quit immediately like he
he did the right thing he knew he was
gonna be a distraction for that company
he did the right thing he did one single
stupid joke
Thomas challenged have done has done a
doesn't very serious disturbing things
including the India stuff please read
about that because it will disturb you
to no end
he was probably don't lady was really
delighted to be done with it who
probably called me and said it was a
plot by him to get off the board I was
like really don't look like an [ __ ]
no I don't think so I'm saying once it
happened yeah right here sorry there's a
there's a thing back here if you run
back here uh hi
I was expecting that you guys will talk
tonight about topics like uber in a job
market Uber's impact on the urban life
uber and the economy
Uber's impact on our social life but you
chose not to talk about any of those
things and I'm not asking you now to
address he can no no I I I'm mostly
curious why you don't find those topics
important and interesting enough to
discuss I do i well I I do and and I
can't tell exactly which you know which
direction you know you're hoping I'm
going to go or which direction the
people who are clapping are going to go
I I I spent quite a bit of time thinking
about the impact on the economy I as
part of my research for the book I
became an uber driver and and so it was
I wanted to experience what it was like
I didn't do it for a long time and I did
it long enough to learn very quickly
that I enjoy my job a lot more than
being an uber driver it's it's it's it's
tough you know that can you what is the
impact of it's not just uber but it's
Airbnb it's all these companies of these
this gig economy and it's not something
you cover a whole lot in the book but
what is the I think it's I think it's
very it's very complicated on the one
hand the uber and airbnb didn't invent
piecework piecemeal work they didn't
invent contract systemize they well
they've they've sort of they've I don't
know made it more efficient maybe with
the by with the smartphone or the web
being the procureur of
of people and and things too for that
piece work I'll just tell you because we
don't have a ton of time you know the my
observation and talking to a ton of
drivers and briefly experiencing it
myself is that out of in in in one
breath uber drivers will tell you the
many reasons why they hate being over
drivers and in the next breath will tell
you why they are uber drivers which is
that they they're they're they're hard
up for cash and for for many many
reasons and they like the ability like
that Hoover gives them the ability to
get it quickly and to do it when they
want to do it which is which is no
trivial thing but like I said they'll
give you the same exact argument in the
same come I'll give you the in the same
conversation those two those two
arguments and what about their impact on
a city because that's self-driving cars
is what you're talking about the idea of
self-driving cars are you or are you
talking about all the the clutter of
cars on the uber and lyft cars on the
road because I think they're I think
they're they're they're different
subjects you know I'm not one of these
futurists who sees what that's how
self-driving cars is going to work
quickly when you talk to these people
they tell you it's a it's a it's a way
it's a it's a when not an if they that
it will happen it is safe but it's going
to take consumer acceptance and
regulation to get there and that may
take quite a bit of time and you know I
just think it's funny it's it's
interesting I'll make an observation you
know Ober is Oberon lift they're
cluttering the streets but lift in John
Zimmer's words are taking cars honking
car taking cars off the road which is a
wonderful you say the quote that Travis
use in the book about horses which yeah
he this was classic right he was asked
in China Travis kalanick was asked in
China do you envision a future where
people don't drive cars themselves and
he said oh no people still ride horses
for leisure even though that was once
our primary form of transportation and I
can I can envision a day when people
take their cars out for for a ride on a
beautiful sunny afternoon right I think
a lot of people and then the quote he
used about drivers though at our
conference where he got in a big trouble
which is the flip side of that where he
called taxi were nowhere he said that
one dude in a car he wanted to get rid
of all drivers he said someday my
business will work when I can get rid of
all drivers and his I know yeah that was
it what the crowd said at the time too
it was a really interesting observation
I think he was telling the truth and was
brutally honest about what a lot of
these people don't say is that they're
hoping to get rid of all humans in the
process of driving and well the drivers
right you know and the the logical
conclusion of the billions of dollars
that that all of these companies are
spending on automation is the
elimination of human jobs which is the
same conclusion of all the other
examples of automation that that's
happening in the economy there he said
it he says it in the in the most
embarrassing foot in his mouth way but
he's correct correct more or less yeah
yeah sorry two more questions thank you
hi I have a question that follows on
your conversation about the culture of
uber I wonder whether there's any
connection you think in from your
research in the culture where there's
sexism and discrimination and you know
driver's incomes are there was a story
in New York about I guess they're being
sued because they didn't pay them enough
they didn't pay them and if I acts that
kind of culture is connected to the fact
that the company's mission is to disrupt
the taxi industry and as you were just
talking about eventually to possibly
take out the transportation sector
worldwide I would imagine that working
in that environment would be very
different from any other job because
you're dealing with all of these large
humanistic ethical moral questions as
you go about your daily tasks so are is
that part of the culture is that
something people talk about are there
connections there so the idea is in the
company they understand the impact that
their business is having on people's
lives I would think that that would be
something employees at various levels
and particularly at top levels but at
all levels would possibly think about or
is it not something that they think of
as as as I'm sure you've heard it
absolutely is something that they that
they talk about and to give you a window
into the mindset of the company
this was for Travis kalanick and the
people around him a badge of honor the
tack and I'm I'm paraphrasing him now
these aren't my words taxi systems taxi
Commission's and taxi owners are corrupt
we are we are doing something about that
corruption they want to keep the number
of taxis available to consumers down and
to keep prices high and we're gonna have
as many cars on the road as possible and
to end drive prices low for consumers
that is that was the founding mentality
of the companies and they they weren't
shy about that what about the second
question of driverless caught the idea
that they may disrupt maybe that's
yesterday's fight fighting the corrupt
taxis right they don't talk about that
anymore doober know about the idea of
getting rid of humans in the driving
process you know the way that might
affect the corporate culture mean I
don't think it's particularly surprising
that there's rampant sexism at a company
that has essentially anti humanistic
values so but you know I mean tomorrow
I'm a humanist right I mean I I think
that what that what Karen and I do and
what you do is going to be the last
industry to be disrupted by robots can
you imagine a robot doing yeah totally
they actually are making them no they're
making them no they are you know that's
not gonna happen in your lifetime yeah
I'll be dead I don't care
right don't you think both of us we're
kind of at the end I think so yeah we'll
be done we don't I do go right ahead
Larry Page that's probably he'll do it
to us right or Zuckerberg okay that's a
great question last question
hi Adam hi Kara thank you so much for
coming my question is what is your
advice for founders aside from you know
not writing these memos and not going to
brothels with your employees don't even
get to the brothel that other good mad
at us just to really really steer away
from this and make sure that the people
that you're bringing on you know embody
the values that will you know get you to
the next stage not let you be dragged
down by this I know there are good
people do burr but you can't the fish
stinks from the head that's a great
thing like think because people change
Zuckerberg has changed Evan Spiegel
presumably has changed talk about that
the founder what happens the journey of
the founder I mean there's there's
little evidence that they I mean Gates
changed after he became a philanthropist
yeah Bezos never changed now Zuckerberg
grew yeah which is different from from
changed and we could you know Steve Jobs
didn't change he also grew tremendously
but you know it's a great question I I I
structured my my Apple book all around
lessons that you can learn from Apple
both for entrepreneurs which Jobs
considered himself to be one and
corporate executives and so wait about
tips what are some of the things hips
from from where do you think you've
interviewed hundreds of founders what do
you think that key assets are or things
to avoid obviously not writing bad memos
but what would think of some as well
I'll give you I mean the one that what
uber did well from the aughts from the
outset was was a core tenet of what
Apple did well which was to be leaves
laser focused on as few things as
possible and when Hoover was was
thriving and growing they were really
focused on one thing which was getting
making uberx huge and you know and jobs
sort of took this to an art form you
know they were gonna say no to more
things and they were gonna say yes to
they were only going to do the they were
only gonna make products they could fit
on a conference room table
we could have a long conversation about
the fact that that's over at Apple now
and it's it's over at uber right there
because they do who burr eats and
they're investigating flying cars and
they're you know transporting kittens
and barbecue and and helicopters and so
I mean I think great great entrepreneurs
and great business executives try to
focus on as few things as possible that
was my learning from writing about Apple
and I think you know some people ask me
what advice would you give Ober and I I
realize well I hate I hate to do that
but that would be the obvious advice
okay lyft is focusing right now got a
great product focus kind of thing
what would you do if you were CEO would
be the first thing no way no way I mean
I you know well you've you've you've
you've kind of done what I'm what I'm
saying I won't do but not you know
you've done it a little you run a
company you sold a company but you've
kept being a journalist the entire time
and I've had you know nibbles over the
years would you be interested in doing
this and I'm just blessed that I've
there isn't anything else that I want to
be doing I get to do a lot of fun things
I like being a journalist I don't I
don't want to be the CEO of uber are you
kidding me all right no they're not
asking but neither either of us right
right no no no and so what did you
imagine will be around in ten years well
you you just predicted that Google's
gonna buy them which i think is very
clever so I would never I would never
counter you Karen but you can have your
own opinion I'm frequently wrong but
never in doubt I'm frequently wrong and
in 10 years there is a ridiculously long
time what I mean is can you be a pioneer
and not necessarily survive the
transition yeah because we've what you
think not you think that you're having
countless time I'm I'm optimistic
because you know I have I have I have
joy and warmth in my heart not because
I'm making a prediction all right what
can I do
yes you do you're a joyful what's the
way look can you do me a huge favor
what no what I've always wanted to get
you to sign me another time afterwards
yes yes I know that I'm very old I got
that thank you
so and so are you because you were you
in our young anyway before the programs
up and running a tiny bit late it is now
an informed tradition to ask all our
speakers the following question what is
your 60 second idea to make the world a
better place don't be snarky no I wish I
by the way they give you 60 minutes
preparation I'm gonna get there because
it's really short I wish I could be
snarky but I just try really hard to do
three three things to say please and
thank you and to be grateful for all the
blessings that I have and I think if you
know if everyone's sort of shot for that
tough goal the world would be a better
place fantastic answer alright let's
give a big round of applause
Adam lijinsky there's a lot in this book
it's a fascinating history of uber if
you want to find out how they got where
they got and thank you for sharing your
thoughts with us it's called wild ride
inside ubers quest for world domination
it's great cover actually it's fantastic
he will be signing this excellent book
wild ride down the hall and copies are
for sale and he's ready to write
personal notes to all of you I know so
please take your time with him and ask
him for whatever you want he is a great
journalist it's one of my favorite
journalists in Silicon Valley had
emotion thank you care
[Applause]